now speaking of the Sinquefield cup one
of the great things about that event was
that we had Magnus Carlsen the number
one player in the world
coming to st. Louis and United States to
play in a tournament for the very first
time he had been in the US before but
only for exhibitions and you know press
events things like that this is the
first time he played a major tournament
in the US as you know he won the event
and it was his final event before he is
going to be playing the World
Championship match against Anand in
India that's gonna start in just just
over two weeks from now so just about
two weeks from now it's gonna be
probably the most exciting World
Championship matched in a long time
because you've got Vishy Anand who's
been on top of the chessboard for our
decades and then you have just a 23 year
old 22 year old who's the number one
player in the world pretty exciting so
I've been going over some of their games
and what interests me is that even in
the games of to such elite players you
can find basic tactics and tactical
themes and ideas that are relevant for
class players even players who are just
starting out I mean you can even find
mates in one sometimes because or in
variations
maybe they wasn't played on the board
but you can find it in variations and
that's pretty exciting it's a good way
to get kids and people into the game to
show them that like even their heroes
make errors or show them their heroes
executing problems that they can find so
we're going to go over some of some
interesting ones today you'll notice
that when you look at chess base one
interesting thing to do is if you're
looking in chess face how many people
use chess base for their training
purposes raise your hand I know I think
a couple or if you don't use chess mates
maybe you use an online database of
games like chess calm or game not this
okay so you might not use chess base but
use some kind of database of major names
that's a great way to learn your
openings
just to go over games I highly recommend
it especially for your openings you know
you can start small start by you know if
you play a thymol against the top-rated
player and they play an opening you
don't know plug it into test base or
chess calm and look and see what the
main lines are even if it only takes you
five to ten minutes start with that and
then sooner or later you're gonna be
spending fifteen minutes 20 minutes and
all of a sudden you're gonna be really
good at your openings so anyway one
thing that you will notice is you get
better at using these types of tools
you'll sometimes look at the event that
the game is being played in and the date
it a lot of times it's easy just to like
look at the game and not notice those
details but they're important for a
couple of reasons
in this case you'll notice that it's a
blitz game now obviously that means that
the quality of the game is lower and
that's probably gonna explain what
transpired here so I don't want any of
Nan hands to be outraged at me defaming
him here because he goes on to make a
bad series of moves of course is oh six
so Magnus Carlsen reading a measly 2625
of course he's well over 2,800 now but
we should say that in oh six he was 1516
mini yeah he was it looks like that was
played in March so he would have been 15
in this position and on play the move
why it's my one sorry the second just
China okay
so we end this position on a non played
c4 so what do we think of that move so
obviously was taking advantage of the
fact that Carlsen just played rook to be
to allowing for a potential knife work
yeah yeah try analyze it and then raise
your hand and let me know what you think
of it yeah that is true but let's get
let's try to get something a little bit
more yeah that's true
try to calculate it all out okay so if
we take on c4 what are the two major
candidate moves for black so if Knight
takes Queen d4 is not quite right look
for further candidate moves exactly very
good so as you can see if c4 in this
position let's take a look again let's
take a closer look in our heads
so after takes on c4 there are two
possible moves for blacks to recapture
that time obviously an on de regional
attend in this blitz gam I'm gonna keep
repeating at the Blitz game is that
after Knight takes he'd be forking the
Queen in the rock so that would be bad
but unfortunately after Knight takes
Queen eight six
why can't Knight takes B to be played 95
and that's actually a mating net so we
can take a look at that on the board so
Queen eight six Knight B 295 and there's
no way to stop this uh this Queen h7
idea because if we move the rook to
create some air there's going to be a
checkmate anyway on a seven or eight a
for the sticklers I always liked this
idea it supposedly tells you what kind
of player you are which checkmate you
prefer maybe the positional players like
the mates that are further away so
anyway that would that would be very bad
so Queen takes e4 instead would also be
bad because
what what bad I guess his relative
because he's gonna lose me Tyrion no
matter why at that point well trying to
do the problem with doing Queen eight
six in just a regular position like for
instance like say you were to play Queen
eight chicks will work before Queen
before Queen eight six is that actually
there are some defensive resources right
so once you this is a key defensive
resource that you see a lot of the time
in the dragon and other cut type of
thing kettle openings but once this
Queen gets in this diagonal it's
actually very good because the Queen can
shuttle back to defense right and now
we're just a million pieces
Bishop f1 trying to take advantage of
the Queen's poor placement and overload
it I want one about a queen c5 feels
like I'm barely holding on they're just
barely holding on just it's actually I'm
wasting Boram of it's a very simple move
it's kind of move you would actually
play it up let's game so it's not really
doesn't require everything gang yeah
just rookie b1 wins right because the
night the night can't be protected and
when it moves this this night one hang
so I think in the game instead not did a
good play after night I think he did
play night C for and then after Queen
age six he just played have sex and lose
of the piece you know obviously lost the
game even though it's a blitz game they
play very well in blitz as those of you
who have watched your local star
Grandmaster Nakamura play can attest to
these guys definitely don't play I mean
they can play like a fool game that's
that's Grandmaster level in a blitz game
it doesn't always happen as this game
evidences but some of the games are just
you you wouldn't you wouldn't even
necessarily be able to tell that easily
without deeper or lock part of the
reason is that is opening preparation if
they actually show the real opening
preparation they could be playing the
first 20 moves instinctively and then
they have to think
the rest and usually their first
instinct is going to be the right move
and that's exactly the reason that chess
grandmasters and masters can get
simultaneous exhibitions they're not
really thinking very much but even just
their instincts is enough to beat people
who are two or three hundred points are
greater than them so there we go
and you know that shows a couple
different tactics it shows basically
mating met target target practice as I
like to call it on h7 and then also just
pin alright his pin so just the simplest
tactics come up in these great
Grandmaster games now that was a blitz
game I do have some real games for you
as well
this is a rapid game so almost like
we're getting closer to classical jazz
this one also just shows that these real
tactics that you look up in book still
come up today among the best players and
we're on so after work takes a five
what did magnets do here
this is kind of interesting because it
shows one of my most my favorite topics
because I think the best way for you to
get better at tactics is just to study
them in books and training programs but
there are certain concepts that are a
little harder to grasp and one of them
is move order move order is a really
important grass concept that is a kind
of inherent to most tactical studies but
isn't always explained it's so important
when you see a tactical idea when you
see a series of captures and checks to
always reverse all the move orders and
make sure that you're looking at all of
them because many many times one of them
is winning one of them is losing one of
them is drawing you just got to look at
all of them Bishop takes h7 check here
is the correct move which was played in
the game and then after King h7 queen b1
check is the idea sorry I meant to ask
you guys and that's of course a double
attack so another double attack they
call it the most common tactic in chess
usually that's especially true at the
amateur level but as we seen in the last
couple games true at the high level a
lot of the time as well and then the
elite level rather usually it comes up
more in variations and then in the
actual game now after Queen takes Bishop
it's very convenient and we actually
attack this rook here in this position
right so that's a key point because if
the bishop on e two captures we can
capture the real con and you sit on a5
and rook case work a6 would allow would
allow us to play Queen b5 and protect
this yeah okay so if Queen g6 instead
now same deal we're gonna play Queen b6
is are you trying to meet me or
something let's see how that's a really
good question okay so I understand what
you're trying to do you're gonna take on
you to first just stop and laid up for
in stuff and then after Queen a5 you're
gonna want really play like instead of
taking my rook you're gonna play Bishop
f3 okay so I the thing is I have a lot
of moves to try to stop you because it's
going to take you 1 2 3
moves to checkmate me and that's a lot
of moves even though it looks like a
good net it's too many moves and the
interesting thing in chess is that Queen
and the key attacker but the Queen is
also the key defender so how to defend
here most easily yeah and their front
Queen to before it just seems like
actually a crushing defense because now
if they try to creep in with Queen h5 or
something we can just play y-yeah Queen
h4 should be very good sorry rather than
that move Queen h4 is is great because
now we also forced the trade to Queens
which is a good thing I mean what else
is there I guess queen of fives the only
other option probably a little better
but also it also it leads to a
problematic move for Wyatt what's your
white light here yeah Queen f4 that's
what I wanted to do at first I wonder if
it's the cleanest because you can't I
understand you can't play here now cuz
you lose and if you play Queen h5 it
transposes with clean 8 4 but you can't
take on d5 and creates three is not
really a threat yet because I have Queen
h4 it really only becomes a threat once
you play g5 really once you play pawn to
g5 it's a threat now I think we could
play Queen B one and then you play
Bishop e4
he's black running we're cached ah
thanks
I think threat might be a strong word
but yeah they could play work h8 I guess
and the next move if you maybe there's
running g5 more than anything with the
idea of Queen Age 3
so the cleanest defense here interesting
wash n I mean we can always Blake we can
only sacrifice and play like efore and
then f3 and that might be a decent idea
if we if we feel like we want to just
like trade off a bunch of stuff because
then at the end of it well I want to
play probably want to play like Queen f4
or something first so you don't may it
may something like this I really want to
give up too many pawns though because
right now it's like fibers for so it's
gonna be I'm gonna have to basically
give up my last pawn I wish I feel like
I should have something easier here like
maybe here just the bravest thing to do
is like just try to keep all your
material and play a move like rook e1
use it be careful because you don't want
to you don't want like a untimely g5
thing to happen now it seems like this
should be okay and then our next moves
gonna be e4 and now Queen f5 yeah it
might be a little bit too too risky
because now you're threatening to play
Queen H each three again so yeah I might
have to just go for it right away and
play the C form of give up some give up
some material in order to stop you from
doing all this bad stuff something like
that
and wood now we're up we're up in
exchange so we're winning it's always
good to try to find the cleanest win cuz
it's not like that easy
anyway game didn't go like that instead
after Bishop h7 just white one
eventually but instead Queen b1
immediately not nearly as strong why
yeah now Bishop takes Knight right away
and after Queen takes b6 what happens
now
you wanna play work b5 or what Kasich
something like that and then you're just
gonna take on f1 and be up and exchange
yeah another another thing is you can
just take on f1 because a1 is hanging in
the variation so Queen 85 Queen Iwan so
yeah it just changes everything the
different move order and so if you
looked at Queen b1 first you didn't
check Bishop takes h7 first then you
would miss out on the win so again
another example of use top player is
like the to top since you guys are gonna
be playing for the World Championship in
just a couple weeks really teaching
through their games even though the
rapid and blitz teaching really basic
tactics right oh this is a really
interesting game I'm actually gonna go
through the opening a little bit as well
on this one this is my favorite opening
the dragon defense anybody here play the
dragon as black it was pretty exciting
to see Magnus play this it seems like he
hasn't been playing it as much lately
but he certainly a sated a few times and
it was exciting to say so this is the
main main line of the dragon this is a
you Kesava TAC so White's planning to
castle on the Queen side and then try to
storm with his pawns over here and try
to really break open the king position
that's one of the negatives of being
ketling that it does give us kind of a
ready-made lever to try to play h4 h5
and capture that pawn on g6 and then
it's gonna be a lot of ugly things
happening on the H file so that's why
Bobby Fischer famously said about the
dragon that it was a really bad opening
for black to play not that it was losing
by force but that
for a practical point of view it was
very dangerous because even a
grandmaster could lose to an ammeter
because the moves for white were
relatively easy to find
he called it sach sach sach mate and and
we'll see some of that in this game so
again the absolutely main line of the
Ragan where white has gone to a lot of
trouble to put his bishop on this
diagonal really more defensively and
than anything it's of course it's nice
that the bishop developed but one of the
main points is that it doesn't allow
black to do a lot of massive trades with
d5 King v1 is a typical move in these
types of positions why do you think King
b1 is a good move to have in the
position a few different reasons but
what's that yeah they see the c1 squared
I think even more than the file it's
usually even more important to diagonal
but sometimes there's kind of a check on
that diagonal and some random variation
it's it's really were they what we call
the Grandmaster move because it's the
kind of move of Grandmaster plays when
it's not a hundred percent clear whether
they want to continue with g4 h for
Bishop eight six because it clearly
gonna be useful at some point in the
game you know blacks enemy attacking on
the side of the board and we're going to
prefer to have our King on b1 it's a
safer Square castling queenside in a
certain sense is only half castling you
can only get our King to see one where
is on b1 that's where it's really safe
yeah
it's very scary I mean it's a scary you
basically just have to play really
accurately I mean you're gonna go for
some kind of counter-attack on the side
playing sometimes people have played
Knight takes d4 instead of 95 and then
play d5 sometimes you play Knight c4
after KK's rook takes c4 and you're
getting some pressure on this on these
squares but honestly it's very difficult
for black to play that's why you usually
see people play it as a surprise where
they prepared all of it and they think
that they're solid against all White's
attacks and then white isn't expecting
it so they don't have they're attacking
methods completely chiseled you'll see
it a lot it's very hard to continually
play the dragon because White's attack
is very scary yeah and that's not as
typical and the reason is that it
happens sometimes but not that often
because really we want to get some
counter play and by taking on b3 we
don't really get our pieces into squares
where we can attack that easily and it
kind of almost helps White's defensive
methods a little bit by doubling the
pawns like we can even sometimes takes
with a C pawn and it's very hard for us
to attack then on the C file because
white will also have a C file now so
yeah you don't see it as often as you
would think because it is a kind of it's
an idea that would spring to mind so it
carlton played this move a six
previously the main line was just the
more simple looking Knight c4 and of
course the whites moves again are very
easy to find h4 h5 can anybody guess
what white played here oh this is
actually white a mother yes white did
play g4 and this is exactly what Fischer
was talking about this move it's not
that hard to find right whereas blacks
next move you kind of have to wonder
usually the the secret is that White's
gonna have a very strong attack whether
he takes it's very hard to generalize
about the dragon because it all comes
down the concrete variations
that being said weights can have a
strong attack if he takes on a chive
right and if you take on g4y can have a
strong attack so you might as well get a
little bit of wood for your trouble and
so black and many of these variations
black actually does take this so-called
poison prawn and now whites move again
is not particularly difficult to find
yeah white plays h5 so we're just
basically almost like a paint-by-numbers
attack like for anybody who's looked at
a Dragon game before this is like really
the classic dragon attack doesn't matter
that we're keeping up a couple pawns
because the attack is just so dangerous
with Kings on opposite sides right
that's the essence of opposite side
castling that we can do all this because
we don't have a king here and let's take
a look at want a stage 5 that's not what
happened in the game of course
Magnus took with the 98 but if pawn
takes h5 the position is just so
dangerous
after something like Bishop to h6 right
you want to try some more moves like
somebody play a move for black knight g6
trying to kind of defend a little bit
the problem is it's hard to get more
defenders into the game like I'm trying
to decide whether I should just play
Queen g5 immediately I think I want to
play just Queen g5 immediately oh and
then you play King h7 okay so that's
good I gain to move and I'll probably
just play here and now after you take
Knight if Phi is gonna be really hard to
me it's just like almost so easy of
course probably those moves weren't the
most accurate for black but it's very
hard for black and meanwhile white just
has all these extremely simple looking
moves now the problem is that you can't
take because well you can but then it
looks like we're gonna win some material
back of course you can try things here
like Queen a5 so we're painting
temporarily but I have a real hard time
believing that I'm not going to
in here I could probably like playing 95
or something something simple oh but you
have sevens doing a really good idea
yeah that looks pretty strong Oh what
happened okay so anyway a question okay
so yeah it's just extremely dangerous to
take with a pond so Knight takes offers
a little bit more cover because at least
if you want to break things open like
that you're gonna have to give up your
rock right which leaves you with one
less rook to attack with which is pretty
important because a lot of times the
idea that you like sack everything and
then you play Queen h2 and work to you
one mating and if you've ever you give
up one rack then it's gonna be a little
harder to arrange all that so an on
preface is the pain with a rook t1
getting everything into play I know
Bishop to h6 again a very classic dragon
attacking move a lot of times people who
are just starting to play the dragon
with white played Bishop h6 too early if
we play it too early in the game there's
a lot of tactics for black actually like
there's too much piling up on d4 and we
lose material but of course here there's
no pressure in the position and I'm
Bishop eight-six makes perfect sense
rook takes c3
a typical dragon move to try to get some
counter play ideas that Queen takes c3
doesn't work because this bishop it
would then be hanging so he's hoping
that after pawn takes c3 that white will
black will get some counter play instead
white played an in-between move here
so what other candidate moves are there
besides taking on c3 but the pond Bishop
takes g7 yes that's that's certainly
possible and that is what happened
and now what do you think why did
can I play Queen g5
started with another move take a minute
take a minute to analyze it a little bit
because it taxis get quite messy now not
that they weren't before
he didn't play pawn thanks G for now he
didn't he did in fact play rock h h5 and
now the idea is that if one case h5 what
what terrible things are gonna happen
this this is a really typical dragon
meeting attack yet so after 20 th 5:25
notice that the knight on e5 can't even
block on g6 because what the Queen on a5
is just hanging so after a point h5
Queen g5 Jack let's try to do this in
our heads not after King 8 7 weight
plays what Queen takes h5 King goes back
to g7 and now what hmm right we go Queen
G Phi check again now the King comes
back to h7 and now what and we have the
little switcheroo
exactly and that's the major piece
attack which is so typical on the dragon
I'll put that on the board and that's
why I mean that's a critical reason why
it's so it's so typical for us to
checkmate in the Dragon and the
sacrifice because this type of meeting
attack happens so frequently where it's
just like black didn't really do
anything that horrendous and he just got
mated that's why a lot of people have to
be very very well prepared to play the
dragon but it's a lot of fun because if
your opponent start sacrificing the
pieces and he doesn't have a mate then
you can win yes
at what point
why are you well the problem is we've
got our bishop here yeah but some of the
time people do play 94 and try to take
on it doesn't happen in certain
variations so it's a legitimate question
and it's just in this case the Bishop
1:8 mv3 almost seems like it's not
really participating but it does have
that useful function of pinning upon so
here after work Age 5 Magnus found a
better defensive move here although just
trying to pick up lots of material for
the back bet and this also should be a
rapid game cause chess classic mines it
doesn't say it in the in the title but
I'm pretty sure mine says just a rapid
event it was like chess960 followed by a
rapid pretty sure I'll check on that
later but I think this wrapping game
I mean just the Magnus Ollie is gonna be
losing if he takes any age five so to
make things more interesting he actually
took on b3 here allowing Anand to play
Queen takes a five which Magnus's begat
Jaeger was that he would get a decent
amount of material after his response
here which is sorry rook takes B to know
what's the idea behind that right
exactly that if King takes B to 94 now
something that's always important to
remember we're sacrifices is that your
opponent's not compelled to take them
right so of course I know I did not play
King takes b2 and simply King to a1 and
then after it takes on h5 white still
can't take on b2 right so black has
accumulated some decent amount of
material for his losses right what do we
what's the material count we've got and
the problem is our King positions still
not very good though and our pieces are
a little bit scattered so even though if
we just count up the material it's not
too bad the situation is a little bit
more dire than that also this Queen
coming to g5 and all those mating ideas
still being in the position alright so
in general the Queen is a lot stronger
when we have a weak King to play with
because the Queen just really excels in
attacking so this is yeah this is a case
in point
I mean Knight see if 94 we're returning
to these very same variations so your
sacrifice didn't help when the two with
the two guys we needed to mate you are
still alive so exactly the same as
before the same little switcheroo so we
use the Queen to remove the pond and
then hello Rock so this game an on one
eventually but there was actually a
faster win in this position which is
really pretty
work eight seven would leave it if you
you want to play rock eight seven right
away and then after King eight seven
Rock h1 King g7 and elites of kind of
the same thing with King f6 right except
now you have a lesser rock no you don't
want that that's really messy obvious
one of the key questions there is really
like after after Queen eight chicks King
f6 Queen g5 King g7 like rook h1 I think
this looks really good at first glance
doesn't it but it's kind of dangerous to
go this way because now what would black
try yeah we got a Czech rook takes b2
very carefully all right because if
working if work takes B to King b2
you have this nice efore idea again and
at the very least it's like even if we
don't have a mate 8 may here which we
probably don't notice that in this
position this is this material is like
really good for black right cuz we're
only down in exchange but we have three
pawns right so that's actually better
for black yeah also in this particular
position I'm not sure at King b3 was the
best but in this position we also have
Knight d2 picking up the f3 pawn as well
all right so I mean this is the kind of
thing that dragon players dream of right
that your opponent will go all out to
checkmate you and somehow in the end
you're left with like six pawn and the
King coming to s6 and then the king
comes the e5 and then the pawns just
kind of Queen and you feel like a great
hero for rebuffing the attack and then
just like getting your bonds line but
instead it didn't actually happen in the
game but there is a really funny funny
way to play here for riot so instead of
playing work on GA
one y-you can actually just play the
chill in between move Knight takes b3 a
great move yeah
and now the Queen has to move and we can
continue with our attack even though
we're down to I mean we're not down
anything actually I mean we're down
exchanged again but now we have the
attack so just uh work h1 is really good
and then if they try to defend with rook
to G to GAA hoping for some salvation
I'm not even sure why I played that move
I guess I wanted to if work h7 I can
slide into f8 or something so now
there's a really pretty way for right to
finish where Kate takes the easy way but
there's a pretty way where KJ is winning
because he can't take because you can't
take cos Queen takes his meeting yes
Queen d7 that's way prettier right I
mean the computer will tell you that
both moves are equally strong but the
psychological devastation of Queen g7 is
much higher that's why we need
objectivity
well actually Queen takes a faith it
doesn't work does it cuz we're KJ King
g7 or Kevin King up six so we now we
have to go back to the prosaic but it
was kind of pretty so that that is like
a pretty fun example of the dragon and
how difficult it is to play it'll be
interesting to see what Carlsen cooks up
more and on will he play his royal apes'
is or will he play something different
he probably will play something
different at some point in the match
because as you saw on this thing filled
top it was really full of surprises and
this match is so important both of them
are trying to surprise each other at
every turn okay this one is a really
important and game lesson which I'd like
to get you guys to spend a couple
minutes on before I just don't don't
call it
anyway so this is white move some of you
might get this more quickly but I want
you to just look at it a little bit
deeper so y están en games good have any
of you heard the the term to be a before
I don't even know if I'm pronouncing it
right oh that has well usually it's
actually a term that they talked about a
lot when chat before the Queen and the
bishop became really powerful in the
16th century the game was a lot slower
because the Queen could only move one
square at a time so it's very hard to
check me can you imagine if you didn't
have the Queen I know even when the
pawns promote you can't make a queen it
was just much harder to check me so it
would take the games would last many
more moves so they would start like 20
moves ahead and agreed-upon
openings for instance so that you
wouldn't have to go to the trouble of
actually making those first 20 to 30
minutes so sometimes people use that
even today to talk about openings that
are really a common and I used it in
reference to endgame which I'm not sure
if that's correct but it is very useful
if you have that databank of a few
really important end games so that you
don't have to analyze them again under
pressure over the board the biggest
example of that is your basic King and
pawn n games you must have those
memorized that will save you a lot of
agony if you have all of your basic King
and pawn and games memorized and when I
mean basic I mean ones like like with
the really really basic ones I don't
mean you have to have hundreds memorized
and same for working games
yes boo and rs pain when was the last
year of up and that was extinct just a
couple years ago right yeah so yeah
Linares pain a very historic and
important tournament if you look at the
games of top players in your divots
you'll see Linares come up again and
again and like I said before it's great
that there are tournaments like the sing
field Cup so one tournament dies and
other comes comes up it's no way to move
so you are you analyzing for right here
yeah yeah what do you wanna play um
there's a better move grandmasters not
allowed bishops II choose not right
either
yeah I think I think Ben's worried that
after Bishop see - there's gonna be a
work h1 check and our cage - hello even
then I mean you play like Kings III but
we're not trying to wiggle out of
anything here you got it actually a very
strong continuation as ye which uses
some really basic in game theory that
you should study after this because
probably you don't know it no work
before the problem is that night night
takes up 596 stops upon from a Dania and
we talked a lot about all the basic
tactics that you can find in the games
of great players even the best in the
world we talked about how you can still
find in between moves and their games
pins double attacks it's all really the
same stuff just on another level more
advanced more complications and here
we've got another basic fact there
guess what tactic is it oh but you know
the tactic the tactic is score so this
one is an example of score
hmm all right
that's kind of slow was I thinking every
seventh day he pen feingold after think
sitting here over ten minutes he just
pushes the pawn that starts with his
name so look for a potential score
obviously you always want to look at
your forty moves
it's our true oh sorry guys well thanks
all for joining us joining me instead of
watching the Cardinals game apparently
if they're down 3-0 you'd be having more
fun with me anyway so always look for 4c
moves in the middle game and opening
that means checks and captors in the end
game of course we should add to that
aggressive pawn moves yes very good very
good so this is a very there's some
really important and game theory around
this team as well that when you play h7
Knight takes f5 you now have this
beautiful move rook b8 just hitting this
square and now the one thing I love
about this is there's a final finesse
that after worked to be a knight d4 it
was what a non played and now Carlsen
problem is that if he makes a queen here
rook takes rook takes Knight takes b3
and that's probably a draw right straw
so instead what is Magnus playing this
to the shine
because before is a good idea and that's
along the right lines but before it's
not that good because black can play
what if we play before
yeah 96 is a really good response
because now what are you gonna do and
and then we're gonna be able to take the
beep on anyway and it's that same kind
of situation so instead of before how do
you execute that same idea of protecting
upon and maintaining your school or
threat yes king b2 is winning for just I
love the end of the King be - in the end
it's like this kind of more aggressive
move h7 followed by the quiet move great
move and you still can't take on 8 7
because of rook b7 scoring and now of
course Nighy 3 we can just take with the
king so we're just gonna be up a full
exchange and so the game went like this
and Magnus converted soon thereafter so
really nice to watch the top players in
the world and in this case the two
players playing for the world
championship in just a couple of weeks
show us basic ideas in the endgame in
the middle game and shows that no matter
what level you are at you can learn
lessons from the greatest players in the
world which is one of the things we love
about chess